[Music]
in the haunting past new oh you almost
lost me but then you got me back that's
some other scary boo
I lost you it haunting oh yeah and then
you got me back past yep
and people are gonna haunt you from the
future just hunting house or hunting
also scary [ __ ] Jill gets stale but then
haunting past is like I'm intrigued
yeah yeah because it's like it's not a
ghost do you still get scared if it's
bright outside and it's really hot and
it's nice like Hawaii no but then come
nighttime I recall what I saw in the
daytime and then I [ __ ] myself
submitted by Erin bill it's pretty good
everyone really has hard something Billy
though yeah actually it's gonna be a E
of you bill
yeah you guys just spill it dump yeah
celebrities are standing up for director
James Gunn after he was fired from
guardians of the galaxy what is this was
he being a racialist no was he being uh
why do you ask questions joking I just
want to know but I love how he has to
respond like yes they answer the
question once I open my mouth I don't
open my mouth he stays quiet and he's
like aren't you gonna answer me so I'm
like just go you wasted so much time
explaining that right oh so you gonna
answer the question away yes James Gunn
got fired
I'm sorry into the galaxy ah three vol 3
because someone who they're calling a
Twitter nutsy they they found really old
tweet or cyber not even a [ __ ] loser
you want they found super old tweet so
this is James Gunn for those of you guys
that don't know what it looks like it
looks cool
there should be a statue of limitations
for people's opinions and Thea that's
such a good for 11 years now like we've
been creating the content I've been a
lot online way longer than that but like
creating content for eleven years right
times [ __ ] change what's funny
changes your thoughts changed like
people what's ok changes heroes yeah
used to believe that if somebody looked
at you wrong it was fine to [ __ ]
shoot them right I don't believe that
now you know but then people change
right it's just silly to hold somebody
to their thoughts and things they did
from like ten years ago yeah think about
who you are now compared to who you are
ten years ago you're completely
different person yeah and then just the
the climate is different like the [ __ ]
that you can get away with is different
like is sometimes just change
everything's changed I was listening to
his podcast and then they're saying that
income tax is actually a new thing so
back in the 1940s
no one got taxed because we paid tariffs
on goods that were shipped from overseas
so if you wanted to buy like a sony
laptop then or I'm gonna do an app buy
something about thought back then but
like if you bought something out some
overseas you paid the tax all on the
things that weren't made in America so
we can protect our American goods so
this whole income tax idea is a
brand-new thing but even say that
taxation is unconstitutional homie yeah
but now that we're born into it we think
it's okay yeah so it's just crazy that
like the Pena I'm like how [ __ ] on
America about that well we pull up that
old [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah tax
yeah they say that the IRS is
unconstitutional what jokes did he make
he looks like the white version of Wes
from Wong foo he does look at doesn't he
yeah if Wes got a little older I could
kind of see I see that dude hey I could
see that it was a hot day so this is
what was tweeted out so it's like a
whole bunch of his tweets fave and
outline if [ __ ] you you're [ __ ] loser
not somebody didn't like guardians of
the galaxy how can you not like that
movie somebody didn't like that's
probably what happened yeah so they've
tweeted at Disney like ah Disney how can
you have a how can you support someone
that thinks like this so some of the
tweets well the person has started
Disney is a [ __ ] Nazi supporter I'll
really couple god dammit who does okay
for the time I guess
so the expendables was so manly I [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of the little [ __ ] boy
next to me the boys are back in town
that's one sweet this guy's funny
doesn't I'm 8 years ago so man y'all
fuzzy boy three men and a baby they had
sex with hashtag unromantic movies okay
I get it 2012 read sweet from a guy
named at Peter Alton I like it when
little boys touch me in the silly place
about that oh [ __ ] just [ __ ] around
like rape jokes too uh let's see oh no
but what if he is a pet or no that's
dangerous what they have it any better
of your kid coming if yeah if he if he
has evidence like you got [ __ ] baby
come on you then tie them up that's true
because you make so many pedo jokes what
the [ __ ] if they took that [ __ ]
seriously on us that would be the same
[ __ ] yeah I mean I'm doing a big
Hollywood film adaptation of the giving
tree with a happy ending the tree grows
back and gives the kid a blow job crazy
don't even think like that well here's
the thing to what I was reading is that
he's like he used to be like a like a DJ
he's gonna be like a shocked DJ like
Howard Stern type [ __ ] you know oh I was
really trying to do like this edgy humor
like shocking damn I can't believe you
just said that time he became a director
yeah yeah but none of that stuff's even
really shocking to me it's just sounds
like someone's just [ __ ] around
because when you say stuff that's so
ridiculous it's like of course not
serious yeah you know I'm saying like
it's like it's just so silly you know
like you when you make a sane like yeah
Expendables so manly I [ __ ] a little
[ __ ] boy next to the other you know he
doesn't actually want to [ __ ] a little
blow a little boy a little [ __ ] boy
next door you know the boys don't have
[ __ ] this hotel shower is the weakest
ever felt like a three-year-old was
peeing on my head
[Laughter]
you're like those fountains and that's
not even that's not even necessarily
sexual though no it's not and it's an
accurate way of describing me cuz I now
I know how strong the shower is it's a
trick [ __ ]
it wasn't a five-year-old it was too
strong and it wasn't a one-year-old
cause it's not that much water right the
three-year-old
yes because of those tweets Disney fired
him oh but what about your Nazi roots
Disney so people are calling Disney
hypocrites a lot because like Disney has
some super racist things they put in
yeah yeah
didn't Mickey Mouse have blackface no no
it was Fantasia there was a little black
girl like blackface horse that was like
that blackface no like she was like a
little one of the fairies or like she
was a half horse it's a fictional
character and all the other little white
horse fairy girls what wouldn't let
wouldn't play with her you know I'm
saying she like that man come on Disney
yeah so James Gunn handed up tweeting a
thread do you want to see a threat I
think the two people to that uncover
these tweets are I found a guy source
but they're like super conservative
yeah like mega mega yeah and they
purposely like dug through oh you know
their past is [ __ ] up like you know
they're hiding some [ __ ] like people
that are like this and [ __ ] rigid
they're the [ __ ] shadiest people over
they like to get [ __ ] in the ass with
the [ __ ] spikey as bad and a horse
they're probably like James Gunn's
telling us all our secrets he's got to
be like shut down I think yeah so James
Gunn said many people who have followed
my career know when I started I viewed
myself as a provocateur making movies
and telling jokes that were outrageous
and taboo as I have discussed publicly
many times as I've developed as a person
so has my work in humor it's not to say
I'm better but I'm very very different
than I was a few years ago today I tried
to route my work in love and connection
and lesson
anger my days saying something just
because it's shocking and trying to get
reaction are over in the past I have
apologized for humor of mine that hurt
people I truly felt sorry and meant
every word of my apologies for the
record when I made these shocking jokes
I wasn't living them out I know it's a
weird statement to make and just seems
obvious but still Here I am saying it
anyway that's the completely honest
truth I used to make a lot of offensive
jokes I don't anymore I don't blame my
past self for this but I like myself
more and feel like more I feel like a
more full human being and creator today
love you love you too all to you all oh
it's so sad a lot of the cast from
guardians of the galaxy they they
tweeted also support now that's kind of
sucked cuz a new directors gonna say
they're not gonna watch it they're not
everyone think he's so good I don't give
a [ __ ] if he talked about a
three-year-old baby pissing on his head
I want to see a good [ __ ] movie Zoe
Saldana said it's been a challenging
weekend I'm not gonna lie I'm pausing
myself to take everything in before I
speak out of turn I just want everyone
to know I love all members of my G OTG
family always will Chris Pratt says
understand this my dear brothers and
sisters let every person be quick to
listen slow to speak slow to anger James
1:19 Oh with the Bible verse bars yeah
David Bautista says what will you do
when the hashtag cyber Nazis attack you
who will stand by you who will cowardly
distance themselves from you who will
punish you for horrible jokes in the
past instead of defending you for
inspiring millions millions
hashtag Redemption hashtag injustice oh
can I have money if I have money I will
[ __ ] hire him I would [ __ ] buy the
[ __ ] the whole brand I will bring
them over to me [ __ ] yeah man
Disney Smith Smith they just bought [ __ ]
40 billion or something well you know
what I'll I'll be the anti Disney I'll
take all the people that they reject
I'll be like Jesus like give me your
tire sick and hungry like the statue of
every yeah yeah I'll be like
you know I'll be the give me all of them
everybody that's rejected from Hollywood
except for hi everyone Harvey wants to
could stay awesome but then everybody
that that that was wrongly persecuted
bring them to me man
I'm will [ __ ] keep making some good
ass art and I'll defend every single one
of them I'll be like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
College is me I like that and give me in
the fish is me just me when I want to go
there pie smells bad meal and now
there's a change.org petition where
they're trying to get 300,000 signatures
as of this moment it's two hundred and
seventy six hundred and twenty-one
almost there if we get those numbers
then they'll put them back on to
directly not I don't know let's help um
sure yeah with every like celebrities of
called out to Disney like saying like
this guy is a good guy like you can't
judge him from his path see unless some
real [ __ ] and evidence has came out to
where this [ __ ] is serious mm-hmm I
think that's when it's like [ __ ] this
guy not only do we [ __ ] this guy we burn
his [ __ ] toes off mm-hmm that's fine
but then if he's just making joke is
just it's just [ __ ] words man yeah
yeah like we've all made jokes there
like if you I mean if it was in the
public spotlight now like would catch
mad [ __ ] for it you know I'm saying like
especially like times has changed
doesn't that suck cause like you know
that the news media like they probably
side with all of us in this room but
they're just like oh we got a type of
awesome [ __ ] so they're amplifying it
and blowing it up out of proportion
where I feel like 90% of the population
is probably like any normal thing Disney
just scared big companies like that
they're scared now now people like even
if they get accused him saying they
people get fired right away you know I'm
saying all it takes is an accusation
they don't want negative P oh yeah yeah
because of all this Michael spineless he
he quit Twitter
oh that who keep Michael Rooker he was
the one that yondu yeah yondu oh he's a
good John do quick Guardians know
whistles in the theme guys cool quit
Twitter is what he said fans and friends
an important announcement from Michael
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ] I'm out this
account will be inactive after today
we're very tired and upset over the
ongoing [ __ ] neither neither I nor
my rep will use Twitter again Twitter
sucks and I want nothing to do with it
thank you all thank you to all who gave
kind words and support see you on
Instagram real quick though I know I
flipped out cuz I thought you undo
wasn't gonna be in the third I know he's
not gonna be in the third one I just
wrote cuz he died spoilers jeez sorry he
was the real bad he may be your father
but I'm your daddy boy yeah dudes the
dopest daddy in the world
[Music]